bonjour elena change vous décrypter pour
nous les images de télévision russe et
de sa propagande oui vous savez que hier
joe biden était au sommet de l'otan
lempire du mensonge comme deep
l'admirent poutine étaient donc réunis à
bruxelles on va voir comment c'est perçu
par la propagande russe mais avant
bienvenue dans la réalité parallèle
judith c'était hier soir sur la chaîne
de télévision d'état rossiya 1 il est 18
heures à moscou 18 heures à paris 20
heures à moscou à voici les titres
[Musique]
c'était un choix difficile mais c'était
le prix à payer elle parle du demi
million d'enfants morts en irak l'ex
secrétaire d'état américaine madeleine
albright choisissez elle même les cibles
pour les frappes en yougoslavie elle est
morte à la date anniversaire des
bombardements
on s'arrête là pour le moment madeleine
albright secrétaire d'état sous bill
clinton elle est morte avant-hier la
propagande russe lui impute dans ce
titre delà du journal télévisé la mort
d'un demi million d'enfants en irak
problème albright quitte ses fonctions
en janvier 2001 la guerre en irak elle
débute en mars 2003 c'est donc une
hérésie totale mais parlait d'enfants
morts pour la propagande russe ça marche
toujours surtout que dès la deuxième
phrase le présentateur fait diversion
madeleine albright nous dit il
choisissait elle même ses cibles pour
les frappes de l'otan en ex yougoslavie
et pour ses frappes et les vilipender
depuis sa mort par la propagande russe
écouter cet autre extrait d'une émission
phare de débat sur la chaîne de
télévision russe pékin en chemin hier
une dame âgée morte aux états unis elle
s'appelait madeleine albright elle est
mort à 84 ans que dieu ait son âme de
pécheresse je ne sais pas quel duel
prier mais c'est celui là qui aura son
âme
celui qu'elle priait sous-entendu par
l'asa temps aura son âme on est en
permanence dans ce discours de
diabolisation au sens propre des états
unis alors expliquons tout de même ce
que nous dit la propagande russe sur ses
frappes de l'otan dans le monde réel le
24 mars 1999 l'otan bombardent la serbie
pour mettre fin au nettoyage ethnique
des albanais du kosovo par le régime de
slobodan milosevic la propagande russe
présente la cij srbije à l'époque comme
un état pacifique a été injustement
attaqué et dans le même temps elle
dénonce aussi les soi-disant doubles
standards des occidentaux car la russie
seraient telles selon cette propagande
aujourd'hui elle aussi en train de
bombarder l'ukraine pour mettre fin à un
prétendu massacre des russophones par
des néonazis ukrainien on justifie donc
le mal des frappes de l'otan par cet
autre mal que sont allés pardon le mal
des frappes russe en ukraine par cet
autre mal qu'on était les frappes de
l'otan en ex yougoslavie et au fur et à
mesure de l'émission le ton monte
jusqu'à nous amener donc à cette réunion
de l'otan hier à bruxelles et voilà
comment elle est commentée lors de cette
émission
c'est un rituel ésotérique je dirais
même satanisme
cela fait longtemps que les anglo saxons
sont dans cette politique ésotérique il
s'agit des frais y est
[Musique]
comment dire de noyer dans le sang leurs
partenaires de façon à ce qu'il ne
pensait même pas à le condamner à
prendre leurs distances vis-à-vis des
processus lancé par les états unis
d'amérique
voilà alors on y est un rituel
ésotérique c'est à sète à nice tu cette
réunion de l'otan pendant plus de deux
heures et demie d'émission les
participants vont diaboliser les états
unis qui aurait donc mis l'europe à leur
botte noter la cymbale igla symbolique
pardon de cette émission levé sur le tee
shirt du présentateur on valoir c'est
l'une des deux lettres avec le z qui
sont le symbole de cette opération
militaire et non pas de cette guerre
nous dit la propagande russe de vladimir
poutine et du soutien supposé des russes
à celle ci donc on retrouve ces deux
lettres vraiment sûr tout l'arsenal
militaire russe actuellement engagé en
ukraine l'habillage du plateau aussi
voyez l'oncle sam les marionnettes qui
symbolise la manipulation par les
américains des européens plus de doute
un sur qui est l'ennemi numéro un dans
cette rhétorique ce sont les états unis
au jeu des russes on est en pleine
guerre froide et le politologue qui
commentent il est membre du prestigieux
clube club de discussion valdaï auquel
participe même plat d'hiver poutine et
vous allez l'entendre il n'y va pas avec
le dos de la cuillère écouter
l'europe est en réalité sous occupation
militaire des etats-unis et de la
grande-bretagne
est périodiquement les européens sont
maculés de sang quand on ira tantôt en
libye tentent en syrie les états unis en
font les complices de leur action
criminelle ils ne peuvent rien dire ils
sont otages de lorsqu'il tient la
puissance des etats unis ils savent que
si l'on demande des comptes aux
américains ont leur rendement drap
housse absolument on parle d'un tribunal
et du nazisme qui prospère dans de
nombreux pays européens surtout les pays
nordiques par là bas vers les pays bas
hélas les européens ont peur pour leur
peau car ils savent que nous les russes
on va leur demander des comptes et on
n'en demandera
lna cette émission elle est très suivi
par la population oui c'est l'une des
principales émissions de débat sur la
lune des deux plus grandes chaînes de
télévision russes elle est diffusée deux
fois par jour trois heures d'émission et
vous l'entendez on y ait un nazisme tout
se recoupe l'asie mire tout type et la
dîmière poutine est là pour des nazifié
l'ukraine et pourquoi pas finalement
l'europe et le monde entier merci
beaucoup et léna volochine plan b
décryptage merci à vous